you goddamn right Jews celebrate
Thanksgiving that's it's a racist
question this is the Jeselnik and
Rosenthal vanity project junior vice
president Thanksgiving special it really
sexing it up for the holidays so what
we're gonna do to thank our listeners
which is pretty much as my fans and and
Greg's mom we want to thank you guys by
answering your viewer emails EDC asks if
Greg and Anthony had to swap careers now
who would be able to last the longest in
their new career ooh that's a great
question I'll tell you why because your
job like if we like switched it I guess
like a Freaky Friday body swap thing I
could probably get through today yeah a
little easy maybe you could probably
pull off just being like I'm sick or
something or like I'm not feeling well
you get through the day like I'm
suddenly really intelligent like yeah it
would be fine oh yeah yeah yeah like
you're suddenly really intelligent smart
enough not to be funny at all
is what your day would be like whereas I
could be like okay bygone Tony Oh Brenda
Antonio Brown did it again and and watch
the money pour in yeah I think I could
last a little bit longer but me as a
person would not be able to tolerate the
NFL and there are rules I would love to
see the copy that you would have you
know I write like a weekly what happened
in week 10 column that comes out on
Tuesday I would like to see you try to
what would you would generate 15 I could
break it it would be bad you could not
do what I do
yeah I have to I have to admit I think
Anthony could last longer I would not I
mean going this the moment that I would
have to go up on stage and do stink food
is where it would all and I think I
could operate the rest of your the rest
of your life like being a dick to
superiors comes fairly naturally to me
like you have to get away with it I
could get away with it I that the part
throughout the life I think I could I
could manage but the second I had to do
something professionally I'd be a joke I
was I was always funnier than you if we
even had to had me and my life is harder
and more difficult and you could not do
what I do
tempo C couldn't carry my jock
I want to bring you into this Lauren W
asks has there ever been a time when one
of you has had to majorly bailout the
other if so what happened why and will
they ever live it down I can read why
would we if we're friends why would you
have to live down bailing someone out
you know what I mean like I remember
once I Greg called me got a car accident
on Santa Monica and asked me to go pick
him up and I did that I was happy to get
out of work there was one time where I
was in jail and I called Greg and he did
not pick up the phone what was this
recently this no this was junior year of
college it was the second time I got I
got I've been arrested twice in a
two-week period for stupid college stuff
nothing serious and one time I remember
calling Greg and the next day he
wouldn't have a I was like you didn't
answer your phone
did you know it was me calling from jail
because if people were getting arrested
a lot at that time and Greg was like
yeah I figured it was you calling now
that's that's a bad moment that reflects
poorly on on my character the fact you
changed it changed your character
immediately like I'm her the look on
your face when I talk to you about it
you were like I knew you would never do
that again it was just one of those
things it's like 4:00 or 5:00 in the
morning and obviously I was probably
sleeping off I had been sleeping for
like two hours sleeping off being drunk
and and you're just like half asleep and
in that state my better my lesser half
you know one out I was just like you
know whatever you don't really think
I've forgiven them friends can change
for the best spooky dog says han theny
when the Pats inevitably beat the
Steelers this oh yeah possibly costing
them a playoff spot how bad will you
take the loss not badly at all I'll be a
little annoyed that it's the Patriots do
it but I'd rather the Patriots than like
son like then like the Browns doing it
in like week 16 or 17 yes you know the
fact that the the Patriots have owned
the Steelers at first was a major source
of friction between us and now it's just
kind of a sad acceptance that you have
and don't tell me that you're okay with
that maybe it's that I don't base my
entire life
football the way the the weather you
have as an adult I'm more into you know
my own career in literary arts I'm not
falling around men bigger than me and
asking them questions yeah you're so
small about yeah you're so mature that
like during big Steelers games you lock
yourself in your room don't don't--i let
are your apartment don't allow anyone
else to be near and scream and yell at a
TV that's like on mute because you can't
like bear the annoyance of the
announcers talking about the game you're
so invested and give me a break that's
right I know myself maybe in the
playoffs I'll do that I love my brother
watch the game but when the Patriots
beat us this year I'll be ok with it and
again and I'll say I'll tell you this
I'd almost rather the Patriots beat us
in the regular season because if we beat
them in the regular season then I know
there's no way we're beating them in the
playoffs that I'm almost like I don't
want to be in the playoffs and right now
we're seated ahead of this is a week
this is two weeks out but we're seated
ahead of the Patriots but yeah I don't I
don't I don't get upset anymore about it
I think that's good this could be the
year eventually these one-sided
rivalries flipping also doesn't seem
like a great Patriots year I'll tell you
those look pretty good if the student
the Patriots played and Tom Brady was
killed during the game you would never
hear the end of it like I would talk I
would I would rub that in your face for
the rest of your life okay guys so Eric
G he says he's a big fan and as a fellow
shark aficionado he'd be interested in
hearing more about Anthony in his
relationship with sharks has he guns got
shark diving if not why not
my relationship with sharks is
negligible you know they can't really
talk yeah you only get to see them when
you're in the water I'm still fascinated
by sharks and that like I just like
watching him swim I like watching him if
I'm in an aquarium I'll go check him out
but I've never been shark diving I've
never been caged that mean because I
hear it's like bad for the Sharks they
Chum the water that confuses the sharks
they don't like the cages like it's not
for me
but I would do it unlike the perfect
circumstances if it was like you know I
just do things with Shark Week every
year yeah and then Shark Week got
commercial and lame and I was like you
know what you're not about the shark
anymore
all right now it's about this
commercialism and I'm not into it I'm
about the funny weeks that how many
years did you shark week four in a row
and then this last year they were like
so and I did a something for it like a
pre Shark Week thing and they were like
I'll come do this show and I was like
okay and they started to explain to me
what it was and I just remember them
being like and then you and I on ziering
you're gonna play truth or dare and I
was like I'm hanging up the phone and
I'm never speaking to anyone at the
Discovery Channel again I used to think
like is this shark fascination of yours
kind of a bit or something but it's not
it's I've been to an aquarium with you
and my kids and when you get near those
sharks your eyes just like light up like
well they move I like the way they move
the badass is that the better the Jessel
mix of the sea that's why we have such a
close relationship
[Music]
you